it's a pleasure for me
troduce professor John Prescott
is the Richard P Fineman professor of
theoretical physics and director of the
Institute of quantum information and
matter
on whose external advising board I had
the pleasure of serving John is a
recovering particle theorists who has
moved into the world of quantum
information and and actually helped
create the what you might call the
second quantum revolution in which we
understand now much more about the
non-intuitive features of quantum
mechanics and the role of information
storage and computation that is
presented by quantum physics and he's
made many important contributions
foundational contributions and our
understanding of quantum error
correction of fault-tolerant quantum
computation of and I suspect we may hear
about today something about information
paradox in black holes for those of you
in in Applied Physics who don't know
what a black hole is it's a parametric
amplifier whose idler is hidden behind
the event horizon
yeah so he's also made important
contributions in topological physics and
it's connection to both quantum field
theory and quantum error correction so
it's a great pleasure for me to welcome
Jonathan for this second lecture well
thanks a lot Steve I guess you'll all
judge for yourselves whether I've really
recovered from being a particle theorist
after today's spot I mentioned toward
the end last time that our progress and
understanding quantum information is
leading to new insights about the
quantum structure of space-time and I
want to amplify that idea in today's
talk and then drill into it a little bit
deeper in the third lecture tomorrow I
started out my career doing particle
physics and cosmology but about 20 years
ago I started focusing most of my
research effort on quantum information
science quantum information science is a
synthesis of three of the great themes
of 20th century thought quantum theory
computer science and information theory
and incidentally just last Saturday we
celebrated the hundredth anniversary of
the birth of Claude Shannon and it's
really quite striking to think about how
Shannon's ideas today affect us on a
daily basis
and in quantum information science we're
largely trying to take insights starting
with Turing into the nature of
computation and Shannon and to the
properties of information bringing them
into the quantum realm as I emphasized
yesterday and in the next few slides
I'll try to review some of the things we
talked about yesterday for
those of you who weren't there or have
short memories I think the way we should
think about this field is we are in the
early stages of the exploration of a new
frontier of physics well we might call
the frontier of complexity or the
entanglement frontier in physics we
explore the short distance frontier of
particle physics the long distance
frontier of cosmology and those are very
exciting and fundamental but so is this
entanglement frontier we are just in the
current age developing and perfecting
the tools to build and control precisely
very complex quantum systems producing
very entangled states which are so
complex that we can simulate them with
our digital computers and we don't have
the theoretical tools to understand very
well their properties or to predict
their behavior and that opens the
opportunity for lots of new discoveries
now on the quantum entanglement which is
the focus of interest in quantum
information science means the
characteristic correlations among the
parts of a quantum system which you can
think about this way we can imagine a
classical book which is a hundred pages
long and then when we read one page of
that book we learn one percent to the
content of the book and after we've read
all the pages one by one we know
everything that's in the book but
suppose it's a quantum book written in
qubits instead of bits with the pages
very highly entangled with one another
that means that when we look at one of
the pages we just see random gibberish
we don't acquire any information that
distinguishes one entangled book from
another and that's because the
information isn't recorded on the
individual pages it resides almost
entirely in the correlations among the
pages that's quantum entanglement and
what's so interesting is that these
correlations are extremely complex so
that if I wanted to express in terms of
ordinary bits all of the correlations
among just a few hundred qubits I would
have to
write down more bits than the number of
atoms in the visible universe and that
won't ever be possible even in principle
and it opens the possibility that we are
entering an age of quantum supremacy
where quantum systems will be capable of
performing tasks that wouldn't be
possible at this were a classical world
now we got excited a little over 20
years ago when Peter shor discovered
that quantum computers if and when we
succeed in building them will be able to
break widely used cryptographic
protocols but the broader lesson we
learn from that is that there are
mathematical problems that have the
property of being hard for classical
computers and easy for quantum computers
can be done with resources that scale
reasonably with this size of the input
to the problem if we have a quantum
computer and we're trying to understand
better what are the problems in that
class for which big quantum speedups are
possible but from a physics perspective
the most important thing about quantum
computing is that we believe though we
can't say for sure that a quantum
computer will be able to simulate any
phenomenon that occurs in nature but
that doesn't mean that quantum computers
don't have limitations there are some
problems for which we don't expect
quantum computers to be able to Chi
achieve dramatic speed ups those include
the hardest problems in the class and P
and P complete problems and P means that
once we find the solution we can easily
verify the solution with a classical
computer and for the np-complete
problems we don't think that it's
possible to do much better in worst case
instances than do an exhaustive search
for the solution and quantum computers
can speed up exhaustive search but only
a little bit quadratically not
exponentially not very dramatic speed
ups like we see for the factoring
problem so one of the likely ways in
which we'll use quantum computers is to
simulate quantum phenom
that are beyond the reach of digital
computers so we'll be able to study
properties of complex molecules exotic
materials and also explore fundamental
physics and new ways by simulating say
strongly coupled quantum field theories
or the quantum behavior of black holes
or the state of the universe just after
the Big Bang so we'd like to have
quantum computers but it's a very
challenging thing to realize large-scale
quantum confusion
computing in part because of the
phenomenon of decoherence then we might
imagine a cat which is both alive in the
and dead at the same time in a coherent
superposition of microscopically
distinguishable States real cats that we
observe are always completely dead or
completely alive and that's because we
can't avoid interactions between the cat
in the environment which in effect
measure the cat and projected onto a
state which is completely alive or
completely dead and that phenomenon of
decoherence that collapse due to
interactions with the environment helps
us to understand why although quantum
physics holds sway at the microscopic
scale classical physics is quite
adequate for describing most of our
ordinary experience if we want to resist
decoherence as if we must if a
large-scale quantum computer is going to
work properly we have to find a way of
preventing information that's being
processed from leaking to the outside
world the environment shouldn't be able
to learn anything about the state of the
quantum computer during the computation
until the very end when we do a final
readout
so quantum computing is hard because on
the one hand we'd like qubits to
interact strongly with one another so we
can perform the quantum gates that are
needed for information processing but we
don't want the qubits interact with the
outside world with the environment
except we do want to be able to control
the qubits and ultimately measure them
and it's difficult to find a physical
setting in which we can satisfy all of
these does it errata reasonably well
but we've learned in principle how to
make quantum computing scalable through
the idea of quantum error correction and
the essence of the idea is that if we
want to protect information that is
being stored or processed coherently
from the outside world then we should
encode it in a highly entangled state so
that when the environment interacts with
the parts of the system no information
is revealed about the encoded state just
like that hundred page book where we
look at the pages one at a time we don't
learn anything about the information
content of the book the information that
we're protecting should be processed or
recorded in a highly entangled state
where the environment interacting with
the parts of the system locally can't
get access to that information so it can
remain protected so we can imagine
preparing a state of a cat in an encoded
form which is both dead and alive and
maintaining it in effect perfectly
isolated from the outside world for a
very long time
and also we've learned how to process
information when it's in that encoded
form now these ideas that we're
mastering having to do with quantum
information storage and information
processing are really deep in general
ideas about physics and so we should
anticipate that those ideas will connect
with other problems in physics perhaps
in unanticipated ways and in fact we're
seeing that happen increasingly often in
recent years for example there's been a
surge of interest among physicists who
work on quantum field theory and quantum
gravity in quantum entanglement and
other quantum information concepts and
in a way that's not so surprising
because the quantum gravity community
has been struggling for 40 years with a
very deep puzzle which really has its
origins in quantum entanglement the
entanglement between the inside and the
outside of a black hole which is
responsible for Hawking radiation so let
me give you a little tease
- you anticipate where I'm heading in
the talk let me talk about Einstein for
a minute now we just celebrated recently
the hundredth anniversary of the general
relativity field equations and Einstein
20 years later after discovering the
field equation I was still
intellectually active he was 56 that
doesn't sound as old to me now as it
used to and Einstein and Rosen wrote an
interesting paper in 1935 in which they
laid out what they saw as the
fundamental problem confronting physics
that the incompatibility of our
understanding of physics at the atomic
scale and our understanding of
gravitation on large scales and their
point of view was that in order to
reconcile the two we should figure out
how to understand atomic phenomena from
the point of view of the field equations
most of us today would turn that around
taking quantum phenomena as the really
primary concept and try to understand
the geometry described by the field
equation starting from a quantum
description now this paper was
interesting for another reason that they
introduced the concept that we now call
an einstein-rosen bridge they
constructed a few a solution to the
field equations which has the geometry
of a wormhole in space they took two
Schwarzschild solutions and they glued
them together at the horizon to sphere
technically that's what they did and
they didn't really understand what they
were doing all that well they didn't
understand the geometry of the
Schwarzschild solution and what they
didn't understand the dynamics of the
solution that they had constructed but
nevertheless it was a original and
somewhat seminal idea it's you can ask
my colleague Kip Thorne about that he's
gotten a lot of mileage out of this idea
of both scientifically and cinematically
now it happens that just less than two
months earlier there was another paper
but I'll get to that in a minute because
I wanted to point out that if there had
been Twitter in 1935 Einstein might have
been inclined to tweet and in fact if
you look at his papers you can find many
statements of 140 characters that would
make suitable tweets so in this one for
example you'll find every field must
adhere to the fundamental principle that
singularities of the field are to be
excluded most of us would agree with
that today and in the conclusion of the
paper we hear that they've taken an
important step towards reconciling
atomic phenomena with the gravitational
field equations well that might be
debatable but coming to that other paper
only about six weeks earlier there
appeared a paper by a einstein-rosen and
their friend Podolski it was the one I
mentioned yesterday which introduced the
puzzles that are eyes from quantum
correlations from quantum entanglement
and this paper too had some tweetable
statements in it I'm being a little
unfair now because we know that Podolski
wrote this paper and then the reportedly
Einstein wasn't too happy with the way
it was written but maybe if Einstein
were tweeting Podolski would have
written as tweets too so one of which
was to judge the success of a physical
theory we should ask ourselves is the
theory correct and is the description
given by a complete and the conclusion
of the paper was that those three
authors felt that the phenomenon of
entanglement indicated that something
was missing however on an optimistic
note they thought a more complete theory
ought to be possible now these are two
papers on very different subjects
written just weeks apart one is about
quantum entanglement the other is about
unusual topology and the gravitational
field equations and it's kind of
remarkable that from our current
perspective these papers really seem to
be about the same thing that quantum
entanglement and wormholes our
complement
in ways of looking at the same
phenomenon so that's where I'm heading
let's talk about black holes a little
bit we've been puzzled by black holes
for a long time ever since Stephen
Hawking discovered Hawking radiation we
have not understood well what happens to
information that gets lost behind a
black hole horizon and not for lack of
trying we still have a very incomplete
understanding of the answer to this
question and when there's a deep puzzle
like this where principles of physics
seem to collide in this case
relativistic causality and the
microscopic reversibility of quantum
dynamics that means there's a great
opportunity for big insights for big
discoveries so let me remind you about
black holes
everybody loves black holes right I mean
how can you not love an object made of
nothing but pure warped space-time
geometry and they're dangerous objects
to the astronaut who foolishly ventures
inside a black hole crosses at event
horizon will not be able to return to
the outside or to communicate to anyone
who remains outside so just to recall
the idea of a black hole we use the
concept with a light cone you know if
there's a flash of light at an event in
space-time and we can imagine
spherically outgoing light signal and if
we look follow that expanding shell of
light as a function of time it defines a
cone in space-time that's the future
light cone of that event in space-time
and everything that can be influenced by
that event P is in the future light cone
of P and what we find by solving the
gravitational field equations is that in
the black hole geometry the light cones
tip inward so that behind the horizon
the future light cone lies entirely
further deeper inside the black hole and
that means it's impossible to escape and
not only the
anyone behind the horizon will be drawn
closer and closer to the singularity
where huge gravitational forces will
tear you apart
now sometimes we like to describe this
geometry using a different kind of
space-time diagram than the one I just
drew a Penrose diagram I'll explain that
because I'll show a few of them during
the talk and the idea the Penrose
diagram is to capture in a very clear
way the causal structure of the
space-time the geometry of light cones
each one of the points in the diagram
represents a two sphere and it's drawn
so that the future light cone of a point
is bounded by two 45 degree lines going
to the left and to the right and so the
picture makes clear that once you're
behind the event horizon the future
light cone can't avoid the singularity
and we can formally map future and past
infinity so they appear to be a finite
distance away and we can fit them on the
page so now
black holes are radiate why is that
classically nothing can escape from a
black hole quantumly radiation leaks out
and one way to think about that is in
the vacuum we know there are quantum
fluctuations which you can picture as
virtual pairs of particles which appear
and then Rhian aisle eight and it may
sometimes happen that a virtual pair is
created one member of the pair gets lost
behind the horizon and the other escapes
to infinity carrying away some positive
energy so the black hole loses a little
bit of its mass carried away by the
radiation and the characteristic
wavelength of the radiation is
determined by the size of the black hole
it has a thermal wavelength it's thermal
radiation with a typical wavelength
comparable to the black hole's radius
there's another way of thinking about
this which makes it a little clearer
what it has to do with quantum
entanglement because even in the vacuum
of a quantum field theory that is a
highly intense
stay we can picture this most easily if
we think about a one dimensional space
and one time dimension as in this
diagram here and in the vacuum there is
a lot of entanglement between the right
side of the space and left side and to
make that operationally meaningful we
can imagine an observer who is uniformly
accelerated along this world line and
that observer has a horizon light rays
coming from the left side of the space
can't catch up with the observer so
everything that observer can measure is
only determined by the right side of the
space and correspondingly even though
the vacuum is a pure state that observer
sees a highly mix tape because of the
entanglement and actually it's a thermal
state why should it be thermal well one
way of understanding that mathematically
is that if I look at the world line of
an accelerated observer the coordinates
are periodic as a function of the
accelerated observers proper time with a
period given by 2 pi over the
acceleration and because of the formal
correspondence between the time
evolution operator of quantum mechanics
and the Boltzmann factor of statistical
physics periodicity and imaginary time
with period beta means temperature 1
over beta so in this case the
temperature in natural units is just the
acceleration divided by 2 pi and if
you're wondering why when you step on
the accelerator of your Maserati and
take off your eyes are not flooded by
thermal radiation you should put in the
numbers remembering that h-bar is small
and C is big so an acceleration of 1 ge
corresponds to a temperature of about 10
to the minus 20 K the wavelength of the
thermal radiation is comparable to the
distance you would have to travel with
this acceleration in order to reach a
relativistic speed but now consider a
black hole and let's imagine we're in a
rocket quasi statically lowering
ourselves closer and closer to the rock
as we get closer to the horizon to
prevent ourselves from falling in and we
have to pump up the thrust of our rocket
so there's more and more thrust as we
get closer and closer to the rise and
that means we have a larger and larger
proper acceleration compared to inertial
observers who fall into the black hole
and correspondingly the state which
looks like it's vacuum to that freely
falling observer appears to be filled
with thermal radiation quanta which are
hotter and hotter because our proper
acceleration is larger and larger as we
quasi statically get closer and closer
to the horizon so there's a thermal
atmosphere near the black hole horizon
most of those thermal quanto when they
try to escape fall back into the black
hole but a few of them that are directed
nearly radially outward will be able to
escape when they reach a distance far
away they've been very substantially
redshifted and wind up with the
temperature which is corresponds to a
thermal wavelength comparable to the
black hole size now once we know the
relationship between the temperature and
the mass of a black hole we can just
integrate the thermodynamic identity tds
equals d e to find the entropy of a
black hole and we get an interesting
answer that the entropy is given by the
area of the black hole horizon times 1/4
in natural units Planck units of area
the Planck length is a very short length
and correspondingly this is a very large
entropy for a solar mass black hole
about ten to the seventy eight about 20
orders of magnitude larger than the
entropy of the Sun for example and so
there's a tension between two things we
know about black holes on the one hand
they are extremely simple objects made
of nothing but geometry which we can
completely characterize by just a few
parameters like mass angular momentum in
charge but quantum mechanically they
appear to be extremely complex objects
to have many many microstates if indeed
that's the right way to interpret the
entropy of a black hole as it is for
other quantum systems
okay so now let's come to the question
of what happens when a black hole forms
and evaporates we can imagine preparing
a pure quantum state allowing it to
undergo gravitational collapse of black
hole forms and the black hole starts to
evaporate it evaporates very slowly but
if we wait long enough the black hole
disappears completely and then we can
ask what happened to the information
that fell through the black hole horizon
where is it now well in the case of
other objects that thermalize in the mid
thermal radiation and cool off
we anticipate that information which was
thermalize is not destroyed but gets
transformed into a form carried away by
the radiation and which is very very
scrambled which is possible to read in
principle but very hard to read and
practice what a black hole is different
from other thermal objects because of
the event horizon and then makes it
harder to understand how the information
could be emitted in some highly
scrambled form one way of looking at it
as I described yesterday is because the
geometry of the black hole is very
highly deform it's possible to draw a
single slice through the geometry which
I've drawn in green here which is a
space-like slice so you can think of it
as a slice of constant time but it can
be chosen so that it crosses both the
collapsing body from which the black
hole formed and nearly all of the
outgoing Hawking radiation that was
emitted while the black hole was
evaporating so if there's quantum
information encoded in the initial state
and it is released in the Hawking
radiation that means that information is
actually at two different places at the
same time that would be cloning of a
quantum state copying a quantum state
and as I emphasized yesterday the
principles of quantum mechanics don't
allow us to copy unknown quantum states
so now we're really stuck because either
we have to admit that the information is
permanently lost and give up on the
traffic reversibility of quantum
dynamics or we have to accept that
cloning occurs and either way we have to
recast the foundations of quantum theory
one way here's here's a way of
describing it with the Penrose diagram
where that green slice is a little bit
easier to interpret the point is that I
can choose this space like slice so that
it stays away from any regions of high
curvature it stays far away from the
singularity so we would expect to be
able to describe physics there using
semi classical reasoning and yet the
quantum information that fell in with
the collapsing body and the quantum
information carried by the outgoing
Hawking radiation both cross that single
slice well one rather desperate way out
of this puzzle is the idea of black hole
complementarity which asserts that
contrary to what you would naively
expect we ought not to think of the
interior and exterior of the black hole
as two different subsystems of a single
system more properly and a theory of
quantum gravity would have to explain
why it's true we should think of the
interior and the exterior as two
complementary ways of looking at the
same system one description is
appropriate for the observer who falls
through the horizon the others our
description is appropriate for the
observer who stays outside it's rather
hard to reconcile the two descriptions
but they are just two complementary ways
of describing the same system so of each
carries the same quantum information
that doesn't mean that information has
been cloned it just means we have two
ways to interpret the same quantum
information well that's the right idea
we should be able to subject it to some
consistency tests we should be able to
ask whether it is operationally
impossible within domain of semi
classical physics that we think we
understand to verify that quantum
information has been cloned so we can
think about that this way as opposed
Alice and Bob want to do such an
experiment to verify the cloning so
Alice carries some quantum information
into the black hole and Bob waits
outside collecting the Hawking radiation
after Alice falls through trying to
decode Alice's information from the
Hawking radiation and once he
successfully decoded it
he then jumps into the black hole as
well hoping to unite with Alice and
verify that her information is also
intact behind the horizon but if bob has
to wait too long it'll be very hard to
do the verification that Alice still has
the information in fact if he waits a
time longer than our log R where R is
the radius of the black hole expressed
in the natural Planck units then it'll
really be too late because by the time
Bob falls in he would have to receive a
signal that was emitted by Alice less
than a Planck time after she crossed the
horizon in order for Bob to receive that
message before he hits the singularity
so if the information came out in a time
less than R log R then Bob would be able
to verify that Alice's information is
both inside and outside the horizon but
if it takes a time our log R or longer
for the information to come out then we
don't seem to have any operational
meaning for the cloning it can't be
verified and at least not in any way we
understand so how long does it take for
the information to come out well there's
sort of a standard conventional view of
how that works which is this then if a
black hole forms and then it starts to
evaporate at first the quantum radiation
the Hawking radiation really is
featureless it doesn't reveal anything
about what fell into the black hole but
after a while the black hole has
radiated away half of its initial
entropy
and now the radiation system is a larger
system has more degrees of freedom than
the remaining black hole and at that
point the information starts to be
revealed so at first the Hawking
radiation is really just featureless
thermal radiation and you can think of
that as being true because that
radiation is still highly entangled with
the microstates of the black hole but
once enough radiation has come out there
aren't enough microstates for the
radiation to be completely mixed now
it's the black hole which is nearly
completely mixed and each qubit merging
in the Hawking radiation becomes
entangled with the previously emitted
qubit so that at the end of the
evaporation process the state is again a
pure state and the information has been
revealed but informations doesn't start
to come out until most of the mass has
been radiated away or about half of it
that's been radiated away and that takes
a really long time because the lifetime
of black hole goes like radius cubed and
flanked units and that's a really long
time for a solar mass black hole it's
about 10 to 67 years however we can
re-examine this question in the case
where Alice carries her information into
a black hole that is already old we've
reached the point where the black hole
is past the halfway point and the
Hawking radiation that's coming out now
is entangled with the radiation that was
emitted previously and we can ask what
happens then
and in that case we can argue that the
information really does come out really
fast so we don't have to wait very long
don't have to receive many Hawking
quanta of radiation after Alice jumps in
for Bob to be able to decode from the
Hawking radiation Alice's quantum state
and this next slide is a little
technical but I wanted to show it to you
because it's very representative of the
way quantum information theorists think
about things so
I want to describe this situation I have
a black hole which is very highly
entangled with radiation that's been
immediate permitted previously and Bob
has carefully collected all that
radiation and he has it encoded in his
laboratory
and then Alice is going to throw in a
few qubits into the black hole and then
there will be some unitary map which
will describe how Alice's qubits get
mixed up with the other qubits and
coated in the black hole and then a
little bit of radiation leaks out which
Bob also collects and the question is
can Bob acting on the system that was
initially entangled with the black hole
plus the additional emitted radiation
decode Alice's qubits so the way we can
think about that is imagine that Alice's
qubits are entangled with some other
system I called it the reference system
and so then what Bob is trying to do is
to extract from the system that he has
access to in his lab the subsystem that
is entangled with the reference system
because those are Alice's qubits how can
e do it or not well we can ask the
question this way does the reference
system decouple from the black hole
after this radiation is emitted where by
D couple I mean does the reference
system become uncorrelated with the
black hole and its quantum state be
described as a product state with no
correlations if it does decouple then
since the overall state is pure and then
was entangled with something initially
the final state is pure and n since its
uncorrelated with B Prime has to be
entangled with ER what's in Bob's lab
and that means Bob and principal can
decode Alice's state that makes sense
now the question is what kind of mixing
transformation will have the property
and how much radiation has to be emitted
for Bob to be able to do the decoding
and as a first approximation we can say
well just suppose that mixing
transformation is just a random unitary
matrix chosen randomly with respect to
the invariant
the unitary group and then we can do the
calculation and say that with high
probability the state will be close to a
decoupled state once enough radiation
has come out and how much is enough
well if Alice Through in K cubits Bob
only has to collect hay plus some
constant number of qubits in order for
the state to be exponentially closed in
that constant to a product state so you
know if Alice threw in a thousand cubits
and a thousand plus 100 cubits came back
the decoupling will work incredibly well
and Alice Alice's qubits can be decoded
by Bob very accurately so it comes out
fast
if the mixing is very thorough and then
we have to ask how long does it really
take to do the mixing and so what we
suggested when Hayden and I analyzed
this is that the dynamics of the black
hole will be very rapidly mixing it's
highly chaotic and roughly speaking we
can understand how it goes by imagining
a random quantum circuit the quantum
circuit consists of pairs of qubits in
the black hole which interact according
to some unitary transformations and in
every time step we pair up the qubits
and perform some random unitary and the
timescale that fixes the time in between
steps is determined by the black holes
inverse temperature essentially its size
and then the information can spread very
rapidly in a number of time steps which
is just logarithmic in the qubits it can
spread among all the qubits so the
mixing will occur at a time which goes
like the inverse temperature times the
log of the entropy that's the hard log R
because the entropy goes like R squared
and beta goes like R so it seems that
the information in this situation really
should come out in time R log R and we
just barely barely satisfy the criterion
that the cloning isn't verifiable
and so the this picture gave rise to a
conjecture for which we have additional
evidence now that black holes are very
fast thermalize errs that they can mix
up information in time which goes like
inverse temperature times the log of the
entropy and then nothing else can mix
faster than that
so how fast is that it takes a time of
about 10 to the 67 years for a solar
mass black hole to get halfway through
the evaporation process but for things
to mix and for the qubits to come out so
that Bob can decode that only takes a
time hour log R which is a millisecond
or so it's a lot faster than you might
have naively expected so this and other
evidence seem to indicate that the black
hole complementarity idea was on the
right track and meanwhile we had other
evidence which in really is is more
compelling that information is not
destroyed by black holes coming from the
holographic duality between Vulcan
boundary the a DSC at t-duality well we
learn from one wall the Sina was how to
put a black hole in a bottle where the
walls of the bottle or what we call CF T
or conformal field theory and the inside
of the bottle is a negatively curved
space a TS anti-de sitter space and the
amazing thing about this duality is that
everything that happens in the bulk
inside the bottle has an equivalent
description of quantum degrees of
freedom evolving only on the boundary so
I can consider the formation and
evaporation of a black hole in the bulk
and it can be equivalently described in
terms of dynamics on the boundary where
there's no gravitation and there's no
black hole and no place for information
to hide so at least in this setting in
anti-de sitter space where we understand
quantum gravity best there doesn't seem
to be any way for information to be
destroyed when a black hole forms and
evaporates now this still leaves a lot
of unexplained it doesn't give us a very
clear picture of how the information
is escaping from behind the black hole
horizon and it doesn't make clear how
the experience of an observer who falls
inside the black hole is encoded in the
boundary so there are open questions but
it's a very strong indication that black
holes can form an evaporate without
destroying information but as I
mentioned toward the end of my talk last
time this idea of black hole
complementarity was challenged a few
years ago by the group called ants black
hole complementarity tries to reconcile
three ideas each of which seems a
reasonable on its own that a black hole
and scramble information without
destroying it that an observer who falls
through the horizon doesn't see anything
unusual at the moment of horizon
crossing but will later on be destroyed
by gravitational forces at the
singularity and that an observer who
stays outside a black hole doesn't see
anything unusual
just the usual laws of local quantum
physics and they argued that we can't
really reconcile all three points of
view and that they advocated that the
most conservative way out is to give up
on the second assumption to say that an
observer crossing the horizon does not
pass through unscathed but gets
destroyed in a seething fire wall right
at the moment of horizon crossing and
they said this crazy thing because of
monogamy of entanglement I explained it
yesterday but I'll remind you that in
classical systems correlations our
polyamorous can be shared in many ways
so when Adam and Betty read the same
newspaper and become correlated nothing
prevents Charlie from reading the paper
as well and then he's just strongly
correlated with Betty and with Adam as
they are with one another quantum
correlations are harder to share so that
if Betty and Adam are very highly
entangled Betty uses up all our ability
to entangle the
and can't be correlated with charlie and
if on the other hand Betty is correlated
with Charlie in a fully entangled State
then she can't be correlated with annum
and the monogamy is frustrating Betty
wants to be highly entangled with Adam
and Charlie there's no way to do it she
can only entangle more with Charlie by
becoming less entangled with them and as
I mentioned this is an important idea in
cryptography and in the study of quantum
matter and in black holes where it's the
basis of the firewall idea that amps
proposed because as they noted if it's
really true that an observer who crosses
the event horizon notices nothing
unusual
then Hawking radiation which is being
emitted now should be highly entangled
with degrees of freedom behind the
horizon that's because the freely
falling observer just sees vacuum no
particles and therefore in the vacuum
there has to be a lot of entanglement
between just inside the horizon and just
outside which is the reason there's
Hawking radiation and on the other hand
if information is revealed from the
black hole then as I've already told you
in the case of an old black hole the
radiation that's coming out now is
highly entangled with radiation that was
emitted earlier and if by the time it
pulls away from the black hole it's
highly entangled with SystemC then it
must already be entangled with C at the
time it's close to the horizon and so
that means the system B wants to be
highly entangled with a so that freely
falling observers think the horizon is
smooth but it also wants to be highly
entangled with C because that's
necessary for information to come out of
the black hole and it can't have it both
ways because monogamy of entanglement
so if information is really going to be
a minute from the black hole we have to
break the entanglement between a and B
and that makes the horizon a very
energetic place that's the firewall
so it was surprising to me about this
amps experiment is that this violation
of the monogamy of entanglement seems to
have an operational meaning it seems to
be something that's verifiable I can
consider a single infalling observer who
is still far from the singularity and
yet can receive information verifying
that B and C are entangled and that a
and B are entangled
so this violation of a fundamental
principle of quantum information seems
to be something you could check in an
experiment within the domain of validity
of semi classical reasoning so it's
really quite humbling that after any
decades of work we can't answer such a
simple question in a way that takes
quantum physics into account as what's
inside a black hole so what are the
possible answers well one is that
there's an unlimited amount of stuff
inside a black hole that's the
information loss scenario I can imagine
keeping a black hole mass fixed by
continuing to throw more and more stuff
in as the radiation is emitted and then
there's no limit to the amount of
information that can get lost behind the
horizon which never comes back in the
Hawking radiation so there's an
unlimited amount of stuff potentially
behind the horizon well that would be
rather disturbing from several points of
view for one thing it would mean that we
couldn't interpret the black hole
entropy the area over for as counting
microstates of the black hole as
counting the amount of information that
could be behind the horizon because the
latter would actually be unlimited
independent of the area and also as I've
mentioned in the case of a DSC of
t-duality on the boundary description
there doesn't seem to be any place for
the information to behind it
oh the firewall answer is there's
nothing at all behind the horizon or at
least that's one of way of interpreting
what a firewall is then not long after
the black hole forms the singularity
joins the horizon so an observer who
encounters the singularity the horizon
at that point is immediately reaching
the end of the space-time and destroyed
at the singularity but that's pretty
crazy because it's not at all what we
find when we study gravitation
classically by solving the gravitational
field equations would say the horizon
should be smooth so this would be a
quantum effect which would really be
profound turning a smooth geometry into
an end of space-time in a region where
there doesn't seem to be any reason for
a singularity to occur classically
because the curvature is low until right
at the singularity another possibility
is that complementarity will still hold
but it's a little more wildly non-local
than we originally imagined and the
lesson seems to be that we have to in
some way relax our notion of locality in
space-time so by that I mean as if the
puzzle is that system B seems to be
entangled both with the interior of the
black hole and also with radiation
emitted a long time ago which is now
very far away there's no violation of
monogamy if we can think of a and R as
being complementary descriptions of the
same system if we can think of the
interior black hole as Rayleigh being
another way of looking at that radiation
which is very far away but that's pretty
crazy because this radiation might be
light-years away by now
and if we take it seriously it means
that by tickling the radiation we could
have some effect which could be seen by
a freely falling observer who falls
through the horizon that would be very
non-local physics so those are the
possibilities that most immediately come
to mind there's information loss
there are firewalls there is complement
complementarity that is profoundly
non-local or we're really confused and
way off track so how are we going to
make progress how we can understand
what's really going on well I think what
we should do
which we have other reasons to do anyway
let's try to understand more deeply this
holographic correspondence in the case
where we know the most about it that is
anti de sitter space
hopefully this which is our best handle
on non perturbative quantum gravity well
when fully fleshed-out help us to
understand the black hole interior now
this holographic duality is really
remarkable it's kind of amazing I've
tried to indicate it here in a drawing
that's easier to interpret in which the
spatial slices are two-dimensional the
boundary has one spatial dimension and
in order to indicate the negative
curvature in the bulk I've drawn this
two-dimensional disc as a pointer a disk
all of the colored regions here
geometrically had the same size but they
appear to be smaller and smaller as you
approach the boundary that encodes the
negative curvature and the way this
duality is supposed to work is that
there is an exact correspondence between
weakly coupled gravity in the bulk that
means classical general relativity plus
small quantum Corrections and a very
strongly coupled quantum field theory on
the boundary and there's a very complex
dictionary that map's the observables
that could be measured locally by the
bulk observers to vary non-local
observables on the boundary the bulk has
an extra radial dimension emergent from
the strongly coupled theory roughly
speaking you can think of that as a
distance scale of renormalization group
scale the theory on the boundary is a
conformal field theory so it has a scale
as well as a spacetime position and
advancing further and further into the
bulk corresponds to looking at the
boundary Theory had longer and longer
length scales flowing into the infrared
from that description it's not at all
obvious why the bulk physics should
appear to be local even
and scales that are small compared to
the curvature scale at the ball and
that's something that's still not very
completely understood but what does seem
to be emerging from our recent insights
is that the geometry itself is emergent
that it is really a manifestation of
quantum entanglement on the boundary so
what are the hints pointing in that
direction well one is the holographic
entanglement entropy which has been
known for about ten years
we can ask the following question
suppose we take the boundary and we
split it into two parts but some
connected region a on the boundary and
the complementary region and we asked
how entangled are those two with one
another how entangle is a with its
complement and that can be quantified by
entropy which is a measure of how much
information is missing to an observer
who looks only at system a the
information is missing because it
resides in entanglement with the
complementary region and the answer that
ryu and taki and Hoggy game in the
context of the holographic
correspondence is that if i want to know
that entropy then in this picture of a
two dimensional bulk I should draw in
the minimal surface in the vault which
connects together the points of region a
and measure its length that minimal
surface because of the hyperbolic
geometry and the vault will dive deep
inside the bulk and then returned a
because that's really the shortest path
through the bulk geometry and the length
of that path in units defined by the
gravitational constant the same units we
would use to relate the entropy of a
black hole to its area that's the
entropy of region a the amount of
entanglement between a and its
complement and in higher dimensions in
three spatial dimensions I would
consider a surface of minimal area and
it really would be area divided by four
G that gives the entropy if somebody
asked me yesterday about measuring
entropy and I said it's hard but this
correspondence relate
entropy to something which is more
directly observable bulk observers can
measure the geometry and thereby
determine the entropy now we can also
ask suppose that we have a that we have
two different boundaries we have two
different strongly coupled field
theories and we entangle them with one
another so now there's a quantum
correlation between two different
boundary theories each of which has a
holographic dual description in terms of
bulk geometry and what happens in that
case and the answer is that those two
boundaries become connected in the bulk
by or home and if there's no
entanglement between the two boundaries
then there's no wormhole connection and
the to bulk geometries are disconnected
from one another so it was small to say
nansuk skin' who had the quite ingenious
idea of referring to this connection as
ER equals EPR meaning Einstein and Rosen
who discovered the bridge equals
Einstein Podolsky and Rosen who first
discussed quantum entanglement at least
in this setting entanglement and
wormhole connectedness are really two
different ways of looking at the same
thing so if we regard that as a general
principle we can think about it this way
suppose Alice and Bob are in different
galaxies and they'd like to communicate
with one another
they would like to be united well in
fact the wormhole that Einstein and
Rosen described is not a traversable
wormhole you can't get from one end to
the other if Alice stump jumps into her
end I shall never be able to emerge at
Bob's end because the wormhole just
keeps stretching and getting longer and
longer and you can never get to the
other side now that corresponds to a
property of entanglement which I
mentioned yesterday which is that we
can't use entanglement for instantaneous
communication Alice and Bob can't use
many entangled pairs of qubits to
immediately send a message from Alice's
galaxy Bob's galaxy well we can do this
suppose Alice and Bob are in different
galaxies and they've had the foresight
to prepare many entangled pairs where
Alice has half of each pair and Bob has
half of each pair and now Alice can
gravitationally collapse all of her
qubits and Bob can gravitationally
collapse all of his and now they have
two black holes which are entangled with
one another according to ER equals EPR
those two black holes are connected by a
wormhole and so now Alice and Bob if
they dare can both jump into their black
holes and be united inside the wormhole
where they'll be able to have a I hope
fulfilling romantic relationship for a
while but ultimately they're doomed to
arrive at the singularity and be torn
apart so it's a romantic but sad story
now let me give you a preview of what I
want to talk about tomorrow which is
something I've been working on for the
last year so with some brilliant
postdocs pistachio Sheeta and Harlow
so I've told you about that this amazing
idea the holographic correspondence it's
it's the most it's the best handle we
currently have on understanding quantum
gravity non-perturbative Lee and I've
told you a little bit about quantum
error correction which is the basis for
our belief and hope that we will be able
to operate large-scale quantum computers
and what I would like to argue in
tomorrow's lecture is that these two
ideas are actually very closely related
that the holographic correspondence is a
type of quantum error correcting code
that when I think of a local operator in
the bulk deep inside the ball which can
be described on the boundary as a very
nominal operator that corresponds to
this feature of quantum codes that if I
want to protect some encoded qubit
using the code I should encode it in a
very highly entangled form so the bulk
degree of freedom which can be observed
locally corresponds to some highly
entangled encoding on the boundary which
is very robust against error so the bulk
geometry actually deep inside the bulk
remains intact even if we introduce
errors on the boundary there's a
redundancy in the encoding which makes
the geometry very robust and part of the
reason I think that's exciting is that
it's another indication that the right
way to think about geometry in quantum
gravity is it's a feature of highly
entangled States and that means that
quantum geometry should be something
that we can simulate and study in
laboratory experiments experiments with
the right kind of highly entangled
States will manifest a kind of
holographic duality which will allow us
to understand more deeply through
experiments features of quantum gravity
like black hole evaporation last year
one mall the Seine and I gave a
presentation to an audience that we
thought would be mostly biologists and
we are trying to explain this connection
between quantum information and quantum
gravity so it's Juan's idea to explain
it this way quantum gravity is like life
and we really want to understand life
and the boundary theory is chemistry and
everything about life is really
fundamentally explained by chemistry if
we just knew how and the quantum
information theorists are chemists they
understand things about the structure of
entanglement which is relevant to the
physics of the boundary and the quantum
gravity theorist thinks all that's very
nice but what they really care about is
life and so what we're trying to find is
a kind of molecular biology we want to
understand life on the basis of the
underlying chemistry and our fruit fly
is the black hole information
it is the toy problem which whiff we
understand it in a non-death won't be
able to go even further to explain life
the universe and everything now if you
listen to string theorists these days
you might hear a conversation like this
one string theorist says to the other
well this is very exciting
entanglement is something to say about
the emergence of space-time but then the
other string theory says yeah I hope so
but it's hard to work on and it's true
it is hard to work on these ideas
because there are very few scientists
who can confidently wield the tools of
both quantum information and quantum
gravity and I think that's in the
process of changing that there's a new
generation of young scientists who have
been internalizing the ideas and
concepts and tools of both quantum
information and quantum gravity and
that's going to accelerate progress or
as one of my collaborators recently put
it now is the time for quantum
information scientists to jump into
black holes and if they do I think great
progress will result
so tomorrow more about holographic
quantum codes
so the question is how do i distinguish
bulk observers and boundary observers
and can these observers communicate well
oh yeah they can a bulk observer can go
to the boundary but the way I
distinguish is you can think of the
boundary theory as being a kind of
boundary condition for the bulk theory
and so everything that happens in the
bulk and this has that this works has a
lot to do with the special causal
structure of anti-de sitter space
everything that happens in the bulk can
be understood in terms of something that
you know happens on the boundary and the
dictionary that I spoke of you know
relates it's most it's a more
interesting dictionary let me put it
that way when I consider bulk observers
who are deep inside the bulk when then
the corresponding boundary observable
could be something very non-local as the
bulk observer gets closer and closer to
the boundary it becomes a more boring
dictionary where we wind up with you
know boundary observable localized where
the bulk observer arrives at the
boundary
space is made of entanglement spaces
space-time is a four-dimensional so the
question is if we have a picture in
which geometry emerges it from
entanglement can we explain why
space-time is four-dimensional well I
wish we could but no I don't think so
because I don't think four dimensions is
the only possibility that makes sense
that there are quantum theories of
gravity and other dimensionalities all
of which can be realized in some type of
holographic description I mean it might
not be you know in general wealth you
know on we it is our misfortune to live
not in anti-de sitter space but to
sitter space at the cosmological
constant which is positive instead of
negative and it is anti de sitter space
for which this holographic
correspondence has been best understood
I actually think holography is a much
more general thing and that we can
understand geometry in anti-de sitter
space or asymptotically flat cases in
terms of some alternative strongly
coupled highly entangled non
gravitational theory but we have a much
clearer idea of how that works in other
cases but this picture does not indicate
anything special about three plus one
dimensions sorry
in some sense and so I guess which that
would then be in the classical general
relativity equations yeah um quantum
mechanics being linear well as far as I
mean you're you you know a lot more
about quantum KS than I do don't you so
one way of thinking one thing I'm way of
thinking about the randomness I just
mean by that that if we consider of
evolving the system forward in time and
then acting with a local operator and
then evolving backward in time we'll get
a much much different state than the
initial state so their sensitivity to
use small perturbations and it's a very
extreme sensitivity it arises because
the quantum information spreads out
among the degrees of freedom very
rapidly now part of your question was
what does that correspond to in
classical general relativity and really
the the rapid spreading of information
is quite closely related to the
exponential redshift as you get closer
and closer to the horizon and you can
think of that the inverse temperature is
entering to determine the length scale
is you know being that that's that's
what's relevant for determining how the
ratio scales when you get close to the
horizon
how long it takes to yeah you can
calculate it I mean and it's well you
can calculate it to a good approximation
if you start out with a big black hole
because you can follow the evaporation
of a black hole and just using semi
classical reasoning until very late in
the process once it gets close to the
Planck scale in the final stages of the
evaporation then it becomes much harder
to calculate exactly what's going on but
that's a that's a tiny fraction of the
total lifetime so in fact it's something
that we can calculate and that's was the
basis of my claim that for a solar mass
black hole it would take ten to the
sixty seven years